patriotism is a sign of extremism
according to the British Army a leaked
document which dates back to 2017 as
exposed to guide used by senior officers
to indicate the signs of extreme and
intolerant behavior in the ranks
according to the document officers
should look out for those who describe
multicultural towns as lost and
personnel who involve colleagues in
closed social media platforms the
leaflet further also calls to watch out
for soldiers who make generalizations
about Muslims and Jews however the
controversial point which refers to
Patriots raised the most questions in
British media we asked people in London
whether they found that particular
recommendation offensive or not
suspicious no what I would it sound
suspicious
but shouldn't do but maybe it does maybe
they think you're over national racist
you know what why would that be
suspicious I think it's a great thing
no I don't I don't agree with that at
all so I don't quite understand why they
would do that Patriots not a bad thing
it's an old-fashioned Channel it doesn't
make you a bad person does it no not
really it's a good thing it's good to be
proud of
it depends Richard why how do you define
it as a lover for a country no
absolutely not
patriotism is a good thing you know if
you look at a lot of the strong
countries around the world you know the
leading countries they're all Patriots
it's wrong isn't it because then you're
because that person could be a normal
person then you could be putting on that
person into their something there's not
footnotes their part the army says that
the leaflet does not suggest that all
Patriots are extremists the defense
ministry further said it was drawn up
following the arrest of four soldiers
who were accused of alignment with an
extreme group
you